the nuclear question is increasingly
being asked i guess and it's not
necessarily being answered at this time
uh in the russian invasion of ukraine
but as time goes forward and as the um
takeover of ukraine does not go
nearly as quickly or nearly as smoothly
as reports indicate vladimir putin
expected it to go
the concern grows that maybe vladimir
putin would bring out the nuclear
weapons uh now when we talk about um uh
nuclear weapons that this can mean a lot
of different things and i think some
people imagine
um
you know hiroshima
nagasaki that's not actually what's
being
considered here based on what russia has
and we're going to talk about that
but that's actually not necessarily a
good thing and i'll explain that in a
moment
an interesting article from defense one
concern rising that putin could use
nuclear weapons russian escalate to
de-escalate doctrine suggests putin is
thinking the unthinkable and patrick
tucker who's a technology editor writes
the world should take russia's
escalating nuclear threats very
seriously senior intel officials told
lawmakers tuesday noting they haven't
yet seen clear indications that putin
would respond to the military setbacks
in ukraine with nukes putin sparked
alarm among nuclear watchers last month
when he ordered the nuclear forces put
on a special regime of combat duty
um
and that uh speaking to lawmakers on
tuesday avril haynes the director of the
office of the director for national
intelligence said the move was mostly
signaling to keep nato from intervening
however
not everyone is so convinced that these
are these are merely empty
uh nuclear threats and then the question
is
what what do you what does it mean what
would it mean if russia actually nuked
ukraine well there's a lot of discussion
of that
and uh there's an article on
heritage.org that yes it's the heritage
foundation it's an accurate uh piece
russia's small nukes are a big problem
and it explains russia has a ten to one
advantage
over the us in non-strategic
low-yield nuclear weapons what are
sometimes called tactical or battlefield
nukes
and this is actually an area of concern
there are some who are hearing about
this and saying well
it's good that russia doesn't actually
have or would would not use the big
nukes here but the way in which it could
be a strategic disadvantage is because
russia has those battlefield or tactical
nukes
and nato
has a much smaller supply of those
putin knows
nato can't really respond
with those particular types of nukes and
this
the concern is could actually be a
signal to putin
if i do this
they're not going to drop like the big
boy on russia
um so therefore
it might be an opportunity to use these
uh types of nuclear weapons tactical
nuclear weapons and
uh there's a lot of you know a lot of a
lot that you can read about these
um these are uh again sometimes called
non-strategic or sometimes called
tactical nuclear weapons and these are
designed to be used on the battlefield
with friendly forces in proximity
in contested areas when we think about
hiroshima nagasaki we're talking about
bombs of such
uh
uh potential to devastate that these are
dropped
when your forces are nowhere nearby with
with sort of wholesale disregard for the
devastation that they're going to cause
the type that is being discussed here
when we say putin might use nukes we're
talking about lower explosive power
um and designed to be targeted much more
specifically now am i saying that it's
it's uh of surgical precision of course
not
of course not but the idea is it doesn't
cause
wholesale devastation and fallout uh
like what we saw in uh in japan during
world war ii so that's the concern
concern is growing and certainly um you
know there's two sides to
how to interpret this going much longer
than putin may have hoped or imagined it
would go on the one hand there as well
that's a good thing putin thought maybe
they could take ukraine in three days
five days seven days it's not happening
they're being met with significantly
more resistance in ukraine and this
could demoralize
and potentially get putin to pull back
that's one side that's the optimistic
side the other side of this from a
strategic standpoint is well
putin expected it to go quickly and it's
not
so it's uh going to push him towards
taking more drastic action and that's
where these tactical or non-strategic
nuclear weapons could come in obviously
we hope that doesn't happen and uh there
really are no i i think the one
additional thing i would say about it is
there is a contingent
that is saying
give me a break
putin
nukes nuclear liberation not gonna
happen
but these are the same people who said
putin massing troops at the border
that's not happening well yes it is
here's the satellite imagery
putin about to invade the donetsk and
luhansk not going to happen and then
putin does
putin going to push further into ukraine
it's not going to happen and then
russian troops do
a lot of the same people saying there is
no nuclear threat from putin
are the same people who said he's not
massing troops at the border he's not
going to cross the border he's not going
to cross further over the border and all
of those things happen so i wouldn't pay
particular attention to those people